b-cells are important component of the
adaptive immune system b-cells when
differentiated becomes plasma cell and
the plasma cell is the source of
secretory antibodies now the secretory
antibodies against a pathogen might
neutralize them or destroy them so
diesel and b-cell receptor signaling is
very important and interesting thing to
know about so here is the portion of the
surface of the B cell here we can see
the membrane bound IgM which is the B
cell receptor along with the B cell
receptor many other co-receptor and
other auxiliary receptors are there such
as city twenty-one city 19 ta PA one and
one of the most important component in
this signaling in the B cell receptor
complex is IG alpha and IG Peeta we
would look at their function and how
they take part in b-cell receptor
signaling one by one now the antigen
binds to CD 21 and the membrane bound
IgM the membrane bound b-cell receptor
of course now normally when there is no
pathogen invasion or in a normal state
the B cell receptors are kind of
separated and segregated moving all
around in the cell membrane kind of
uniformly distributed but whenever it
encounters a pathogen or a pathogenic
antigen the B cell receptors kind of
cluster in the lipid rafts of in
specific subdomains of the B cell
surface these lipid rafts are most
important in terms of signaling many
events many molecular and cellular
events happen in these lipid traps and
we would talk about that serially so one
of the most important event is a
receptor clustering now important kinase
is such as Lin kinase can be part of
these lipid raft and these Lin kinase
can phosphorylate several components of
the B cell receptor
cluster so the B cell receptor cluster
one of the most important part is IG
alpha and IG beta now these are also
molecules of IG superfamily and they
have something called immune receptor
tyrosine kinase based activation motif
or items these items are site for
phosphorylation by SRC family kinase
such as the lean kind the limb kinase
which is a SRC family kinase it can
phosphorylate IG alpha and beta items
and the phosphorylated items are
actually docking site for adapter
molecules such as blink now other kind
of SRC family kinase is like psych can
also bind to the phosphorylated IG alpha
H beta and can trigger several molecular
and cellular event which we would learn
eventually
now this blink adapter is very important
in terms of signaling because it could
serve like a platform for several
signaling components to come in and set
up a new signaling system for example
map kinase signaling can be triggered if
linked work like an adapter and as a
result of the map kinase cascade the
well-known map kinase cascade it might
allow the binding of a p1 family
transcription factor into the nucleus
and allow the transcription of several
important genes once a gene that is
transcribed is known as CC + d1 no CC
and d1 codes for cycling D and if we
learned about cell cycle we know that
cyclin D is super important for cell
cycle progression because it it
phosphorylates
pRb and allow the e to F to bind to its
target and give rise to cyclin e which
is in turn important for replication and
thereby procreation of the cell cycle
so whenever cyclin D is produced as a
result of antigen binding that
means visa now can defied and form
multiple different B cells so B cell
proliferation can occur right now this
is the outcome the cellular outcome of
the signaling now let's talk about a
different one we have already talked
about that Lin kinase can phosphorylate
the items of IG alpha n IG beta Lynn
kinase can also phosphorylate the items
of Sillitoe h1 and cd19 now these
phosphorylated residues are actually
docking hub for kinase is like pi3
kinase now pi3 kinase can convert pick
two to pick three now pip3 is a docking
site for a kt and a very important
kinase now
ATT has widespread function including
cell survival including cell division
and many others a kt can phosphorylate
and inactivate several approve up optic
molecules like packs and bad thereby the
overall signaling can prevent the death
of the B cell and indirectly it promotes
the survival of the B cells the B cells
upon antigen binding give rise to these
whole downstream signal which would
allow their division their survival and
prevent they're built so this is how the
peace cell signaling work the other arm
of the signaling which is triggered by
site kindnesses so I can activate direct
phospholipase c gamma now phospholipase
c gamma can cleave the tip to and give
rise to ip3 and DHE the ip3 can in turn
go and bind type its receptor in the
endoplasmic reticulum which would allow
calcium to be released in the cytoplasm
an increase in calcium calcium level can
be sensed by calcineurin which is a
phosphatase now calcium ring can be
phosphorylated now in fact is kind of
restricted to the cytoplasm until
calcineurin d phosphorylate that now the
dephosphorylation of the infant
allows the infant to be localized into
the nucleus and give rise to gene
transcription
so in calcium-dependent way a variety of
gene transcription Network is activated
upon calcium binding so this is a very
important function of b-cell receptor
signaling I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up and don't forget to like share
and subscribe thank you